laut einer studie macht das sperma des
mannes glücklich frauen müssen es dafür
nur essen studien sollte man möglichst
seriös verfassen damit sie auch ernst
genommen werden einige studien sind aber
so komisch dass man sie wohl auch in
wissenschaftlich korrekter form kaum
ernst nehmen kann
die top fünf super skurrilen studien
jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction auf
platz fünf ok cupid ist eine dating ab
wie viele andere auch was okay cupid von
den anderen unterscheidet die app bzw
die betreiber der app haben eine studie
veröffentlicht die folgendes resultat
lieferte 80 prozent der bisexuellen sind
nicht wie sexuell okay jetzt seid ihr
gefragt wer von euch glaubt alles was im
internet steht bitte melden
ok und wer von euch hat all seine
kontaktinformationen bei facebook
korrekt und vollständig ausgefüllt seht
ihr also da ist das ergebnis der studie
quasi vorweggenommen warum geben
unternehmen für eine studie die den
wahrheitsgehalt auch kontaktbörsen prüft
held aus dass da viel geschummelt wird
ist doch wohl jedem klar oder
na ja wenn nicht dann gibt es ja diese
studie die nummer 4 der skurrilen
studien der schon einmal auf dem
oktoberfest in münchen war der wird das
wissen alle bierkrüge haben am griff
eine kleine einfärbung grund dafür sind
heftige auseinandersetzung mit dem krug
als waffe mit der körper aber kann ein
bierkrug nicht mehr derartig genutzt
werden der griff bricht dann nämlich
einfach ab bei flaschen sieht das ganze
etwas anders aus wie genau das wollten
schweizer forscher wissen
sie fanden heraus dass leere flaschen
gefährlicher sind als volle flaschen
warum die forscher das wissen wollten
gute frage
auf der drei der seltsamen studien wer
eine große schnauze hat bekommt größere
und gesundheit kinder die größe der
schnauze beziehungsweise des schnabels
ist bei der fortpflanzung der stockenten
zwar nicht entscheidend aber laut einer
studie sei die farbe des schnabels
entscheiden früher war ein wohlgeformter
körper ein zeichen des wohlstandes die
stockenden dampf sehen das heute noch
ganz ähnlich wenn der potenzielle
partner ein besonders kräftig gelb
gefärbten schnabel hat seit dieser
perfekt für eine paarung die daraus
entstehende meyer werden besonders groß
und im inneren seien auch deutlich mehr
abwehrstoffe zu finden
von einer großen schnauze aus kann man
bei uns menschen zum glück nicht sofort
auf den nachwuchs schließen
auf der zwei ist das essbare sperma es
gibt ja so einige skurrile sechs studien
diese aber ist echt seltsam
laut einer studie hätte das sperma des
mannes sozusagen glücklich machende
eigenschaften
frauen müssen es dafür nur essen
die daily mail berichtete über diese sex
studie der universität new york wie der
weg bis zu dem resultat aus gesehen hat
kann man sich ja wohl vorstellen die
frage die ich mir stelle ist aber wie
soll denn eine solche methode in
therapeutischen sitzungen oder therapien
überhaupt angewandt werden oder wenden
sich demnächst spender an pharmakonzerne
um sperma pillen zu vertreiben wie schon
gesagt die studie ist echt ein bisschen
seltsam und die methode wäre im
therapeutischen bereich glaube ich ein
wenig schwer umzusetzen
und die absolute top 1 sie vielleicht
unwichtigste studien aller zeiten
es geht um ein problem das
ausschließlich männer betrifft und das
auch nur äußerst selten verfasst hat
diese studie nicht wie man annehmen
könnte ein mann sondern die chirurgen
sagte chandra mischung aus neu delhi im
fachmagazin indien petrics erschien
trägt die studie folgende namen achtung
genau mitschreiben safe and painless
manipulation oft inhalt redmond also ihr
habt richtig gehört es geht in der
studie darum wie männer geschickt und
schmerzfreiheit ihre vorhaut aus
reißverschlüssen befreien können
auch bei dieser studie kann man sich den
weg bis hin zum ergebnis vorstellen muss
man aber vielleicht auch hier nicht was
man sich aber auf jeden fall mal
vorstellen sollte ist folgendes tausend
mal schnelleres wlan mehr dazu erfahrt
ihr hier im video zu rap und zum blog
geht es hier unten und schreibt uns doch
mal zu der einen oder anderen studie was
ihr meint warum die überhaupt
durchgeführt worden ist oder kennt ihr
ähnlich überflüssige studien
lasst es uns wissen und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran